Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在我们深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的好消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是无休止地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的行业，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am joined by my guest, Jonathan Paddy, who is an assistant
这些原则对你同样适用。挑战赛还将送出由丽莎亲自颁发的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士一对一的咨询小时。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体账号，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。在今天的节目中，我邀请到了乔纳森·帕迪，他是一名助理
psychologist living and working in London. We talk through so many great topics, including trauma, community psychology, and his experiences of wanting to see more black male psychologists in the profession and how he goes about supporting and encouraging people to come forward and be part of a really encouraging aspiring community hope you'll find today's episode so useful if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified.
心理学家，目前在伦敦生活和工作。我们探讨了许多精彩的话题，包括创伤、社区心理学，以及他希望看到业内有更多黑人男性心理学家的愿望，以及他是如何支持和鼓励人们勇敢加入这个充满鼓励的有志者社区的。如果你想成为一名心理学家，希望你会觉得今天的节目非常有用，并让它成为你的向导。有这个播客伴你左右，你离取得资格证就不远了。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. You might well be listening to this when it's released, which means we are in the middle of application season for educational psychology and for clinical psychology. And yeah, if you would like some more advice or support or guidance, please do check out the free Compassionate Q&A replays, which you can find on my YouTube channel, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do please bear in mind there's the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book too, which get wonderful reviews and can be really normalizing and validating. And today's guest and I are talking all about that sense of being validated or being seen and feeling like you're part of something. And that's something that those books and my own Aspiring Psychologist membership does really well. But it's a really, really interesting conversation. I am joined by
这里是玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。你收听这期节目的时候可能正值节目发布之际，这也意味着我们正处于教育心理学和临床心理学申请季的高峰期。是的，如果你需要更多的建议、支持或指导，请务必查看我YouTube频道（Dr Marianne Trent）上的免费同理心问答回放。请记住，还有《有志心理学家合集》和《临床心理学家合集》这两本书，它们获得了极好的评价，能带来极大的正常化和认同感。我和今天的嘉宾谈论的正是这种获得认同、被看见以及觉得自己是某个群体一部分的感觉。这也是这两书以及我自己的“有志心理学家会员计划”做得非常出色的一点。这是一个非常非常有趣的对话。我邀请到了
Jonathan Paddy, who's an assistant psychologist, and I hope you'll find it really interesting. I'd love to know your thoughts on this episode. Please do connect with me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And do come and hang out with me on the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. If you find this content helpful, please do like, subscribe, share it on socials. That would be wonderful. And drop the odd comment in here and there too would be fabulous. Anyway, I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this episode and I hope you find it useful. Hi, my name is Jonathan Paddy and I'm a guest on
乔纳森·帕迪，他是一位助理心理学家，希望你会觉得这期节目非常有趣。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法，请在社交媒体上与我联系，我所有的社交账号都是Dr Marianne Trent。也欢迎加入我们免费的Facebook群组——由玛丽安·特伦特博士创建的“有志心理学家社区”。如果你觉得这些内容对你有帮助，请点赞、订阅并在社交平台上分享，那就太棒了。顺便在这里和那里留下几条评论也是极好的。无论如何，我期待在这期节目的结尾与你再次交流，希望你会觉得它很有用。嗨，我叫乔纳森·帕迪，我是你即将收听的
the podcast episode you're about to listen to. When Marianne and I recorded this episode we didn't realise that it was going to come out during Black History Month and so we haven't mentioned it in the podcast at all so I thought it was important to come on and just speak about it very quickly before we listen to the episode. So Black History Month is a month in which we actively try to centre the Black experience, something that I think is incredibly important. We've managed to do that serendipitously in this episode. I think it's really important to have these conversations about the experience of Black men, of Black people and other minoritised groups.
这期播客节目的嘉宾。当玛丽安和我录制这期节目时，我们并没有意识到它会在“黑人历史月”期间播出，因此我们在播客中完全没有提及此事。所以我认为在收听节目之前，抽空露面简单谈谈这件事非常重要。黑人历史月是一个我们积极尝试将黑人经历置于核心地位的月份，我认为这极其重要。我们在无意中在这期节目里做到了这一点。我认为就黑人男性、黑人群体以及其他边缘化群体的经历展开这些对话真的非常重要，
But these conversations need to be also had outside of these specified months. I think if we consider the lack of diversity within clinical psychology as a profession, so both in terms of the staff members and the clients that we see, it's really important to discuss how we can do the work to become a more equitable profession and I think that includes considering the power that we all hold and to use that to support people from minoritized communities anyway and thank you so much for having me on the podcast and I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. Hi just want to welcome along our guest for today, Jonathan Paddy. Hi, Jonathan. Hi, thanks for having me. Thank you for saying yes. And we got chatting on LinkedIn
但这些对话也需要在这些特定月份之外继续进行。我认为，如果我们考虑到临床心理学作为一个职业在多样性方面的缺乏——无论是从员工团队还是从我们接待的客户来看，讨论我们如何努力使这个职业变得更加公平就显得非常重要。我认为这包括思考我们所有人拥有的权力，并利用这种权力去支持来自边缘化社区的人们。无论如何，非常感谢邀请我参加这个播客，我真心希望你们会喜欢这期节目。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾乔纳森·帕迪。嗨，乔纳森。嗨，谢谢邀请我。谢谢你答应。我们在领英上聊过
and we'll come to what we got chatting about. But firstly, I think it's always really interesting for our audience to learn a little bit about you and your psychology passions and career um what first turned your head in the direction of psychology donathan yeah that's a good question um i mean i started at a level so it's just a choice that we had at a level and i thought this seems like it's about people i'm interested in people and so and so i went for that um and just found it really really interesting really and i took that on and did that university and i actually didn't didn't want to do clinical psychology at all and going into university had a few lectures on it and really didn't didn't want to do it and it turned out i just had been misinformed really so my lectures were really diagnostic based like um yeah we look at the
我们稍后会谈到我们聊了些什么。但首先，我认为对我们的听众来说，了解一点关于你、你的心理学热情和职业生涯总是很有趣的。乔纳森，最初是什么吸引你走向心理学方向的呢？是的，这是一个好问题。我是从A-Level（高级水平考试）开始的，这是我们在A-Level时的一个选择，我觉得这似乎是关于人的，我对人很感兴趣，所以我就选择了它。然后发现它真的非常非常有趣，我把它带到了大学。其实我一开始根本不想做临床心理学，
um dsm and yeah the diagnostic manual and kind of trying to diagnose people explicitly and i was like i kind of want to do a bit more than that really. And as I got to find out a bit more about psychology, clinical psychology specifically, I was like, oh, actually I do really like that. I am really interested. And then I think personally, I had, there's some things going on in my life, my friends' lives where their mental health
去大学前只听了几场讲座，真的很不想做这个。结果证明我其实是被误导了。我的讲座非常基于诊断，比如我们看
was really affected. And at the time we didn't really think about it as a mental health difficulty but just some tough times going on for that person and the more I had some psychological language and knowledge and reflecting on that I was I don't know just really interested in trying to support people in that situation especially who didn't have the language or weren't able to to name it and term it and term it that yeah great and yeah I think I don't know what they're teaching in universities but I certainly had a module on clinical psychology as part of my degree and it was so boring and it was taught I think by a clinical psychologist but it was so boring. And it was taught, I think, by a clinical psychologist, but it was so unengaging and one sided and flat.
DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）和诊断手册，有点像明确地试图去诊断别人，当时我想：我其实真想做点比这更多的东西。随着我进一步了解心理学，尤其是临床心理学，我觉得：哦，其实我真的很喜欢。我真的很感兴趣。然后我觉得个人方面，我生活中、我朋友的生活中发生了一些事情，他们的心理健康
And I definitely didn't look forward to those lectures. And I definitely wasn't thinking, I can't wait to be a clinical psychologist. It was only when I think it was the same lady was stood on stage in the final weeks of my third year and was telling us more about the actual job and then said oh it's so difficult to get onto I wouldn't recommend it it's really competitive I was then like I give that a go then um but yeah why aren't they being a bit more representative about what us clin psychs actually do and how amazing this is as a career and I guess that's part of why I do this podcast really is to shed a light on the different things that are going on in the world of clinical psychology because I honestly believe that we're in the best best job in the world and you know you're a little bit further ahead in your career but I love that you're you're looking ahead to where you want to be as well yeah yeah I mean it's interesting that you
受到了很大的影响。当时我们并没有真正把它当作心理健康困难来看待，只是觉得那个人经历了一些艰难的时期。随着我掌握了更多心理学语言和知识并对此进行反思，我不知道，我就是对尝试支持处于那种情况的人真正产生了兴趣，尤其是那些没有这种语言能力或无法为之命名和界定的人。是的，太棒了。是的，我不知道他们在大学里教些什么，但在我的学位课程中，我确实有一门关于临床心理学的模块，它是如此无聊。而且我认为它是由一位临床心理学家教的，但它是如此枯燥、单方面且乏味。
say that and you had a lecturer say that it's competitive and you shouldn't go for it I think it seems like a lot of people have had that that spiel from a lecturer or someone senior to them at some point it is competitive I'm finding that very much so but I still think it's worth it's worth going for for sure I think it's important it's needed it really is it really is and we need such a range of different people um within this sphere you know so that we're offering representative services but also so we're we're being able to feed in our own rich experiences just before we met we were we're speaking about you've lived kind of all over the country really and had a very different
我绝对不会期待那些讲座，也绝对没有想过“我迫不及待想成为一名临床心理学家”。直到我认为是同一位女士在我的第三学年最后几周站在舞台上，给我们讲述了更多关于实际工作的真实情况，然后说“这太难进去了，我不推荐，竞争非常激烈”，当时我才想：那我要去试一试。但话说回来，为什么他们不能更具代表性地告诉我们临床心理学家实际在做什么以及这份职业作为一种事业有多么惊人呢？我想这也是我做这个播客的部分原因，就是为了阐明临床心理学世界中正在发生的不同事情，因为我真心相信我们从事的是世界上最好的工作。你知道，你在职业道路上比我稍微超前了一点，但我很高兴看到你也在展望你希望达到的未来。是的，是的。我的意思是，有趣的是你
upbringing because of that um and i think you're now living in london um but you know absolutely we should be having you know people that haven't just had you know the same experience um you know it's really important stuff and and I know that's um that's partly what we're going to be talking about as well but before we go on to that if we could have a bit of a chat about what you're doing now so you're an assistant psychologist at the moment yeah yeah so I'm currently an assistant psychologist um I work in a high intensity user team so there's a few of them around the country but um I guess for those who maybe haven't heard of it um we essentially help people who present to A&E quite frequently or ring a London ambulance quite frequently as well, usually for some kind of unmet need, whether it's mental health, social, physical health, usually a combination of all three, and try and support them.
这么说，而且你有一位讲师对你说竞争很激烈，你不应该去尝试。我觉得好像很多人在某个时候都从讲师或某位资深人士那里听到过这番说辞。竞争确实很激烈，我发现情况确实如此，但我仍然认为绝对值得去尝试。我认为这很重要，这是必需的，真的非常需要。我们需要这个领域内有各种各样不同的人，
So our team is made up of psychiatric liaison nurses, some psychology, and a little bit of psychiatrist time as well but yeah that's what I do currently great I remember reading something it was a long time ago it might even have been in the early stages of my qualified life so probably about 12 years ago talking about the the spend and the cost that's indicated in people who do regularly call the emergency services when actually their needs are not emergency based and it was staggering it was staggering and it obviously it overstretches an already overstretched system can you tell us about you know in case people are why can't you just go to ambulance you know why can't you just go to hospital could you tell us a few a bit more information about why why that's not
这样我们才能提供具有代表性的服务，同时也能融入我们自己丰富的经历。就在我们见面之前，我们还在谈论你几乎在全国各地都生活过，因此有着非常不同的
the best place for somebody who's having you know an existential crisis or something they can't sort out I know it might sound um you know quite simple but I try to make this podcast standalone really so that people don't need to go off and google stuff so are you happy explaining a little bit more about that Jonathan? Yeah yeah I can I can have a go um so I think I guess to to say yeah to start off I think people should use A&E if they feel like they need to I think that's really important that's one of the things that we we say to a lot of our our clients and if you feel unwell and you feel like you need support from any go um in terms of addressing what you're saying about the the cost there is yes significant cost attached to people
成长经历，我想你现在住在伦敦。但毫无疑问，我们应该让那些不仅仅只有千篇一律经历的人参与进来，这真的很重要。我知道这部分也是我们要讨论的内容之一。但在我们继续之前，如果我们能聊聊你现在在做什么——你目前是一名助理心理学家，是吗？是的，是的。所以目前我是一名助理心理学家，我在一个高强度使用者团队工作。全国各地有几个这样的团队，但对于那些可能没听说过的人来说，我们主要帮助那些频繁出入急诊室或频繁拨打伦敦急救中心电话的人，通常是因为某些未得到满足的需求，无论是心理健康、社会问题还是身体健康，通常是这三者的结合，我们试图去支持他们。
frequently calling um emergency services that's that's definitely true and we see the numbers for that. I think you wanted me to touch on why maybe it's not ideal to be calling the London Anglican as often as some people do. I think it's really difficult to tell people not to do that. I find it quite difficult to do that because usually what we see is there's been an unmet need or people have falling through the crack somewhere so that they're just trying to seek support and show that they need they need help i think maybe a way that could help that is to maybe fund services or to um i guess provide more high intensity user teams across the country that could maybe intercept and help people and um catch those people earlier really
所以我们的团队由精神科联络护士、一些心理学人员以及少量精神科医生时间组成。是的，这就是我目前在做的工作。太棒了。我记得很久以前读过一些东西，甚至可能在我刚获得资格证的初期，大概是12年前，谈到那些经常拨打急救服务电话的人所产生的开支和成本，而实际上他们的需求并非紧急情况，这个数字令人震惊。这确实令人震惊，而且它显然给已经超负荷的系统雪上加霜。你能告诉我们，以防有人在想“为什么你们不能直接去叫救护车呢？为什么你们不能直接去医院呢？”，你能给我们提供更多信息，说明为什么这对
I think I find it quite hard to tell people not to not to do that at all and does that answer your question it does yeah you've done a really nice job then as I was listening to you I was thinking about a book that I'm reading at the moment it's called A Man Called Ove I don't know if you've read it it's um it's set in in Sweden and it's about a little man who lives by himself. And I don't think it's going to be much of a spoiler to say that in the first chapter, he's trying to end his own life because he's not having a very nice time. And as the chapters unfold, he becomes more and more immersed in the community and in his local connections. And what is really wonderful about it is that community psychology feel.
经历生存危机或无法自行解决问题的人来说不是最佳去处吗？我知道这听起来可能挺简单的，但我真的试图让这个播客独立成篇，这样人们就不必再去谷歌搜索了。乔纳森，你介意多解释一点吗？是的，我可以试试。所以我想，首先，我觉得如果人们觉得自己需要去急诊室，就应该去。我认为这非常重要，这是我们对许多客户说的话之一：如果你感到身体不适，觉得自己需要急诊的支持，那就去。至于你说的关于成本的问题，频繁拨打电话给紧急服务确实会产生显著的成本，这是绝对真实的，我们也看到了相关的数据。
And actually, what I think we get quite often in services is quite often people are just lonely or they're not being able to find a purpose. They're not being able to find a purpose, they're not being able to find where they fit. And I think there's definitely how we, you know, include people in society so that they do feel that they've got a function and so that they feel, I don't know, like there's a point in them existing and that we're relying on other people, we're part of something. And, you know, I think when we feel disconnected from others, and even in especially living in cities, sometimes you don't even know your neighbor, you know, and you might be suffering similar struggles as a parent, or, you know, even somebody living independently, or as a widow, experiences of grief and trauma.
我想你希望我谈谈为什么拨打伦敦急救电话可能并不理想。告诉人们不要这样做其实非常困难，我发现这相当艰难，因为通常我们看到的是有未得到满足的需求，或者人们在某些地方被体制遗漏了，所以他们只是在寻求支持并表明他们需要帮助。我想解决这个问题的一个方法可能是资助服务，或者在全国范围内提供更多的高强度使用者团队，以便能够进行干预、帮助人们并更早地接住这些人。
And we just don't get a chance to to know that. And so, yeah, I'm I'm really excited about any initiative to kind of think about community psychology and starting people to be able to have conversations. So just before we hit record, I was telling you that I'd been to an open evening for a secondary school yesterday. And I really liked what they were saying that actually they put on events that are not just for pupils, not just for prospective parents and pupils, they put on community events. That's something I really like about our primary school as well, because it is an opportunity to get together, to do something different, to start conversations, to start connections. And, you know, I'm all for that.
我觉得告诉人们完全不要这样做真的很难。这回答你的问题了吗？回答了，是的。你刚才解释得非常好。当我听你说话时，我想起了一本书，我目前正在读，书名叫《一个叫欧维的男人》。我不知道你有没有读过，故事背景设定在瑞典，讲的是一个独居的小矮人。我想说的是，在第一章中他试图结束自己的生命，因为他过得并不快乐，这应该算不上太大的剧透。随着章节的展开，他越来越深地融入到社区和当地的联系中。而这本书真正美妙的地方在于那种社区心理学的氛围。
Yeah, that sounds really great. is that you're trying to sort out people's problems in a way that negates and bypasses emergency services, which are always going to have a higher cost per minute or a higher cost, I don't know quite how it's priced up, but a higher cost and more of a planned and responsive approach to what you're doing but it sounds like the work you're doing with your clients or your patients is very different from from person to person yeah yeah very much so i think there's a huge spectrum um of people that we see so there's people on one end who are coming to um amy quite frequently for things that we can help with. I don't want to say they're simple, but they're easy for us to solve because we can mobilise the system in a way to support them.
实际上，我觉得我们在服务中经常遇到的是，人们往往只是感到孤独，或者无法找到人生目标。他们无法找到目标，无法找到自己的归属。我认为这绝对关乎我们如何将人们融入社会，让他们觉得自己有某种职能，让他们觉得，我不知道，他们的存在是有意义的，我们依赖其他人，我们是某个集体的一部分。你知道，我觉得当我们感到与他人脱节时，尤其是在城市里生活，有时你甚至不认识你的邻居，你知道的，你可能作为父母或独立生活的人或寡妇，正在经历着类似的创伤和悲伤挣扎，
We do have people at the other end of the spectrum where it gets really, really difficult for us to help them. We're a very, very small team. There's not many of us. And we're one of the biggest um teams high intensity user teams in the in the country i think yeah so these people struggle with significant mental health difficulties and social difficulties so that might include um not having a fixed abode and so that might be really difficult for them as well as some physical health difficulties and so they could have a broken leg, for example, or an infection somewhere. So people have a combination of these things, which are relatively complex,
而我们根本没有机会去了解这些。所以，是的，对于任何旨在思考社区心理学并开始让人能够进行对话的倡议，我都感到非常兴奋。就在我们按下录音键之前，我告诉你我昨天去了一所中学的开放日。我非常喜欢他们说的话，实际上他们举办的活动不仅仅针对学生，也不仅仅针对潜在的家长和学生，他们举办社区活动。这也是我非常喜欢我们小学的点，因为这是一个聚在一起、做点不同事情、开启对话、建立联系的机会，你知道的，我完全支持这一点。
and you have to work really hard to mobilize another hepatology team or the, some other team, orthopedic teams, sometimes even A&E to try and help these people. And it can get really, really complicated. But I think we're doing some really good and interesting work things I've never really done before so yeah every day is it's very different. It sounds brilliant and I from knowing what I know about people and knowing what I know about trauma I'm guessing there's a lot of trauma running through a lot of the work that you do, even if it's not something that the client would necessarily describe as trauma.
你必须付出很多努力去动员另一个肝病学团队或者其他团队、骨科团队，有时甚至是急诊室（A&E）来试图帮助这些人。这可能会变得非常非常复杂。但我认为我们正在做一些非常棒且有趣的工作，有些是我以前从未做过的，所以，是的，每一天都非常不一样。这听根据我对人们的了解以及我对创伤的了解，我猜在你所做的很多工作背后，都贯穿着大量的创伤，即使这不一定是客户自己会称之为创伤的事情。
I think when we hear stories and we we know about their upbringing, trauma recently and how difficult it is for people, how difficult these stories are and how difficult these lives are. To us, I guess, they're stories of people that we're trying to help and support, but these are people's experiences and people's lives and trying to pay attention to that and trying to help them as best we can through it I think yeah one thing I was just going to say is that I don't think people
我想，当我们听到一些故事，了解到他们的成长经历、最近经历的创伤，以及人们面临多大的困难、这些故事有多沉重、这些生活有多艰难时。对我们而言，我想，这些是我们试图去帮助和支持的人的故事，但这也是这些人的真实经历和生活。试着去关注这一点，并尽我们最大的努力陪伴他们度过难关，我想，是的，我刚想说的是，我不认为人们
not everyone likes using the word trauma and so it's trying to be really careful about how we bring that to the table yeah yeah that's an important consideration and when I worked in inner city Birmingham there was lots and lots of different cultures and lots and lots of different languages and lots and lots of different understandings of mental health and what that means, whether it's stigma, whether it's embraced. And I used to work with many different interpreting kind of interpreters for for supporting the clients to engage. Is that something you find that you are doing quite a lot in your role, Jonathan? So not as much, actually, which is surprising. We're in an area where there's a lot of people from Bangladesh.
并不是每个人都喜欢使用“创伤”这个词，所以在我们如何将这个话题引入对话时，必须非常小心。是的，是的，这是一个重要的考量。当我在伯明翰市中心工作时，那里有许许多多不同的文化、许许多多不同的语言，以及对心理健康及其含义的许许多多不同的理解，无论是存在耻辱感还是受到接纳。我过去常常与许多不同类型的口译员合作，以支持客户参与治疗。乔纳森，你在自己的角色中也经常发现自己在做类似的事情吗？其实没有那么多，这挺让人意外的。我们所在的区域有很大一部分孟加拉国人。
So I would expect to be using interpreters a bit more. But so far in my role, I haven haven't as yet I'm not exactly sure yeah that that does surprise me um for it for especially for a London service it was certainly in Birmingham I would say sometimes as many as a third of my clients were probably um using interpreters I would say um do you think it's about well I guess your service is a bit different because it's people that are not you know necessarily engaging in other services but I don't know it's interesting isn't it why why are you getting mainly people that can speak English you know being referred to your service or repeatedly phoning for emergency services I think it's something about being able to
所以我原本预期会更多地使用口译员。但到目前为止在我的岗位上，我还没有怎么用过，我也说不太准。是的，这确实让我感到意外，特别是对于伦敦的服务机构来说。当然在伯明翰，我会说我的客户中有时甚至有多达三分之一都在使用口译员。你觉得这是因为……嗯，我猜你们的服务有点不同，因为对象是不一定主动参与其他服务的人，但我不知道，这很有趣，不是吗？为什么你们接触到的主要都是会说英语的人呢？或者说那些频繁拨打紧急服务电话的人？我想这大概与能够……有关
navigate the system so you need language to navigate the system somewhat and yeah I think that that's probably what's happening so if people aren't able to speak the language and don't have people around to support them and they can't get access to support and to help. So I think I just can say people in our team do sometimes see people with interpreters, but not very often. I think it's a really interesting thought to think about. And I might need to take that back to our service lead and think about how we can see if there's a gap gap see if we're missing people
在这个系统中导航，所以你需要某种语言能力来在系统中导航，是的，我想这大概就是原因所在。因此，如果人们不会说这种语言，身边又没有支持他们的人，他们就无法获得支持和帮助。所以我想我想说的是，我们团队的人有时确实会遇到需要口译员的患者，但并不常见。我认为这是一个非常有趣的思考点。我可能需要把这个反馈给我们的服务主管，思考我们如何才能找出是否存在盲区，看看我们是否遗漏了某些人
because they're not able to engage in services or communicate their needs yeah really interesting point and I guess I was then thinking about whether there's potentially a role for an audit you know are you auditing who is presenting at emergency services and looking at their demographics to see where you can perhaps better engage it's always quite fun to think about where you can potentially get some research and dissemination stuff to put on your form is that something that that goes on quite routinely anyway Jonathan to help inform what you're doing? Yeah so at the moment there's quite a lot of conversations about audits and thinking about the kind of patients that we see.
因为他们无法参与服务或表达自己的需求。是的，这是一个非常有趣的观点。我想我当时在想，这是否可能涉及开展一次审计（audit）的角色，比如，你是否在对前往紧急服务就诊的人员进行审计，并查看他们的人口统计数据，从而了解你在哪些方面可以更好地进行干预？思考一下在哪些地方可以获得一些研究和传播材料来充实你的表格，这总是挺有意思的。乔纳森，这在你们的工作中是常规进行的事情吗，用来为你们的行动提供参考？是的，目前关于审计以及思考我们所看到的患者类型的讨论确实挺多的。
So our criteria really is that we need someone to have attended A&E over 10 times in the last 12 months. So we do have a minimum criteria. But what we find is that the people that we end up seeing often attend a significant amount so I'd say significant being like 25 times a month something like that and so the system is encouraged to get in contact with us and refer this person so that we can try and help support them um yeah 25 times a month gosh that's that's almost once a day isn't it but I think you know as a commissioner you might see that as a bit of a nightmare as a client but I think what we see as professionals are gosh that's a lot of distress you know that's a lot of uncontainment that's a lot of feeling lost alone scared and really not sure what else to to do and when I worked in a
所以我们的标准实际上是要求某人在过去12个月内去过急诊室（A&E）超过10次。因此我们确实有一个最低标准。但我们发现，我们最终接待的人往往就诊频率极高，所以我说的高频率是指一个月25次左右这样的情况。因此，整个体系会受到鼓励来联系我们并转介这个人，以便我们能够尝试协助支持他们。嗯，一个月25次，天哪，那几乎是一天一次了，对吧？但我想，作为一个专员（commissioner），你可能会觉得这简直是一场噩梦；而作为客户，但作为专业人士，我们的感受是，天哪，这包含了多么巨大的痛苦，包含着多么深的不被安抚感，包含着多么强烈的失落、孤独、恐惧，以及对接下来该做什么真的感到不知所措。当我在一个
youth prison sometimes young people would harm themselves and there was different viewpoints around how that should be responded to because some people were like oh well if you're too nurturing then almost the nurturing and the kindness from the nurses that care for you then become part of the problem because it's part of the motivation it's like a secondary gain but sometimes it's a primary gain if I hurt myself then I can be cared for but you know we're not going to start delivering services that are not humane or not kind and of course what we want to think about health service employees is that they are compassionate that they are kind and it should feel like a safe place like a port in the storm but there might well be more appropriate
青年监狱工作时，有时年轻人会伤害自己，对于应该如何应对这种行为，有着不同的观点。因为有些人会认为：“哦，如果你表现得太有养育关怀之情，那么照顾你的护士所给予的关怀和善良，几乎就会成为问题的一部分，因为这是动机的一部分，就像是一种次要收益。”但有时这是一种主要收益：“如果我伤害了自己，我就能得到照顾。”但你知道，我们不会开始提供那些不人道或不友善的服务。当然，我们希望对卫生服务员工的看法是，他们富有同情心、善良，这里应该感觉像一个安全的地方，就像暴风雨中的避风港。但可能还会有更合适的
ports for storms and I guess that's what you're trying to do yeah it's really interesting that you you say that um yeah we do have some situations where people are coming to amy repeatedly or calling the london ambulance repeatedly and and yeah a second secondary gain of that is is is that they're receiving good care and support and some attention and people are people holding them in mind i think we're talking about loneliness just previously people holding their in mind I think which weren't loneliness just previously people holding their mind I think it's really important for people to have that and yeah I think it does it does contribute sometimes to the presentation and I do try and practice what I preach a little bit I do speak to strangers in the street. I developed a friendship with a lady who since moved away,
暴风雨中的避风港，我想这正是你试图在做的事情。是的，你这么说真的很有趣。嗯，我们确实有一些情况，人们反复来到急诊室，或者反复拨打伦敦救护车服务电话，并且，是的，其中的一个次要收益就是他们得到了很好的照顾、支持、一些关注，以及有人把他们放在心上。我想我们刚才还在谈论孤独感，有人把他们放在心上。我想我们刚才还在谈论孤独感，有人把他们放在心上，我认为这对于人们来说非常重要。是的，我认为这有时确实会促成这种表现。我确实在努力践行我所宣扬的理念，我会在街上和陌生人说话。我和一位女士建立了一种友谊，她后来搬走了，
which is really sad, but she was 87 when we knew her best and she lived by herself and me and my children would go around and visit her. And she was just so delighted to have a phase of her life that she thought had passed her by, which was young children coming around to play. And it was really lovely. And I befriended another little chap. I won't say what his name is, but, you know, we often kind of familiar strangers
这真的很令人难过，但当我们和她最熟的时候她已经87岁了，她一个人住，我和我的孩子们会过去看望她。她感到非常高兴，因为她迎来了人生中一段她以为已经逝去的阶段，那就是有小孩子们过来玩耍。这真的很美好。我又和另一个小伙子交了朋友。我不会说出他的名字，但是，你知道的，我们经常算是那种熟悉的陌生人
that walk similar routes at similar times of day. And, you know, I know his name and what I know about him, and I know what he gets up to. And I love that. I love that. But I know that lots of people don't like talking to strangers. They don't like forming connections. But I do try to do it where I can and try and make a difference where I can as well which is again a little bit off topic but it's related isn't it no it definitely
在一天中相似的时间走着相似的路线。而且，你知道，我知道他的名字，我知道我了解他的一切，我也知道他在忙些什么。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。但我知道许多人不喜欢和陌生人说话。他们不喜欢建立联系。但我确实尽我所能去这样做，也尽可能在我的能力范围内带来改变，这也是有点偏离主题，但又是有关系的，不是吗？不，这绝对
is related I'm thinking about I'm smiling sorry I'm thinking about London and that that isn't so frequent in in the city people often head down marching to wherever they're going. And although saying that, recently we've had a couple of new neighbours move in and they've been super friendly and come and said hi. I want to move into our house. And a couple of years ago, one of the neighbours brought some food over and I was super, super surprised and shocked. But it was a really nice thing to for her to have done which is just great I love that I saw just on I don't know if you're part of it but there there's a massive massive Facebook group called I think it's family tips lockdown support or
是有关系的。我在想——我笑了，抱歉——我在想伦敦，这在城市里并不那么常见，人们通常都低着头，径直朝着他们要去的地方走去。尽管话虽如此，最近我们搬进来几位新邻居，他们超级友好，过来打招呼，还想搬进我们的房子。几年前，其中一位邻居送来了一些食物，我超级超级惊讶和震惊。但她能这样做真的非常棒。我太喜欢了。我刚刚看到——我不知道你有没有加入——有一个规模非常非常庞大的Facebook群组，我想它叫做家庭小贴士封城支持（family tips lockdown support）或者
something so it obviously started in lockdown but now it's a massive group that gets really good engagement and one of the viral posts on there recently was one of my new neighbours has just bought around all this food for me. And she speaks this language. And I want to be able to culturally appropriately respond. How should I do that? And it was really, really interesting hearing people's descriptions of that. And, you know, well, if she speaks um you know urdu then she's probably a vegetarian and actually maybe she wouldn't even be happy with accepting food
类似的名字。所以它显然是在封城期间开始的，但现在它是一个互动度非常高的庞大群组。其中一个最近病毒式传播的帖子是：“我的一个新邻居刚刚给我买了一大堆吃的。她说的不是这种语言。我希望能以一种文化上得体的方式做出回应。我该怎么做？”听到大家对此的各种描述真的非常非常有趣。你知道，比如“如果她说的乌尔都语，那么她可能是一个素食主义者，事实上，她甚至可能不会高兴接受来自陌生人的食物，
from strangers so you might be better to give her a card and give her some flowers um you know and I just I just found it so interesting and you know people were like oh that's such a lovely thing to do why don't people do that more but I love that you know even two days like, oh, that's such a lovely thing to do. Why don't people do that more? But I love that, you know, even two days in a row, you've now told me that that happens as well. Yeah, yeah, it definitely does. I think what I was thinking about when you said that story is about how the diversity in that group is really helpful because you're able to then tap into different languages different cultures and you can better respond to to that act of kindness which is which is great we're partly meeting today to think about the importance of culture and the importance of identity and the importance of um connecting with people that you feel you've got similarities with so do you want to tell us a little bit about that and why that's so important to you Jonathan? Yeah yeah I can definitely do
所以你最好给她一张卡片，送她一些鲜花。”你知道，我只是觉得这太有趣了。人们会说：“哦，这真是一件暖心的事，为什么人们不经常这样做呢？”但我很喜欢，你知道，甚至在连续两天里，你现在也告诉我这种事也会发生。是的，是的，确实如此。我想当你讲那个故事时，我脑子里想到的是，那个群组中的多样性是多么有用，因为你能够借此融入不同的语言、不同的文化，并且能够更好地对那种善举做出回应，这真的很棒。我们今天聚在一起的一部分原因，是思考文化的重要性、身份认同的重要性，以及与那些你觉得与自己有相似之处的人建立连接的重要性。所以，乔纳森，你想跟我们多聊聊这个以及为什么这对你如此重要吗？好的，我当然可以
that um so I'm someone who's been in psychology for a little while I think like five-ish years and I like you said before I've lived in a lot of different cities in psychology um and to be honest I haven't come across many many men to start with but many black men at all and i think i've met two two black clinical psychologists and that's been black man who are clinical psychologists and that's been um with me actively seeking those people out to get some advice about about things. And it's all kind of come to a head recently where I've applied for the course a couple of times and haven't been successful. And I was thinking about community and support. I think there have been a number
这样做。嗯，我是个从事心理学有一段时间的人了，大概有五年左右吧。就像你之前说的，我在心理学领域曾在许多不同的城市生活过。说实话，一开始我并没有遇到很多很多男性，特别是黑人男性，我想我只遇到过两位黑人临床心理学家，那还是在我主动寻找这样的人去寻求一些关于各种事情的建议的时候。最近这些情况似乎集中爆发了，我申请这个课程好几次了，但都没有成功。当时我在思考社区和支持。我认为有许多
of things that I've kind of focused and get my head down in trying to achieve this thing. And I've kind of forgotten about the other parts outside the psychology. And so I thought, you know what, maybe I need a community and maybe other people are feeling similar to what I am. So with that in mind, I kind of went about seeking people in spaces, so using Facebook groups that you've spoken about, the place on LinkedIn, which is what I think you saw and then on Twitter as well so just reaching out on all the social media spaces and to try and
事情是我一直专注于并埋头苦干想要去实现的。我有点忽略了心理学之外的其他部分。所以我心想，你知道吗，也许我需要一个社区，也许其他人也有和我相似的感受。带着这种想法，我开始在各个空间寻找志同道合的人，比如使用你提到过的Facebook群组，LinkedIn上的平台——我想你就是在那里看到的——还有Twitter上。所以，就是在所有的社交媒体平台上伸出援手，试图
recruit some people and yeah we've managed to do that and start this group which has been really really great actually really great. Well to you and um i think there's absolutely a space for if you can't see it it's harder to feel like you can be it but if you can't see what you need it's it's absolutely great to create your own um and what sort of you know is it just conversations that you have do you organize events events? Are there big plans there? What's going on currently? And have you got a view for how that might develop in future? Yeah, so we've had potentially, I think, three or four meetings.
招募一些人。是的，我们成功做到了，并创立了这个小组，实际上真的非常非常棒。祝贺你，并且我认为绝对存在这样一个空间：如果你看不到它，你就更难觉得你能成为它；但如果你看不到你需要的东西，自己去创造一个绝对是极好的。那么，你们通常会做些什么呢？这只是你们进行的对话吗？你们会组织活动吗？有什么宏大的计划吗？目前进展如何？对于未来它可能会如何发展，你有什么看法？是的，我们目前大概进行了三次或四次会议，
Three meetings, I think. We've got another meeting next week. So, yeah, I guess this is something that I had the idea about and I reached out to people, but I've currently got a co-facilitator on board who's been really helpful and we can work on things together. I'm hoping that we can get one more so between the three of us we can try and curate and develop this space. I think two of the important principles is that, okay, yeah, so we want to grow from each other really, you know, so having the space in the community so we can, yeah, better
我想是三次会议。我们下周还有另一个会议。所以，是的，我想这是我产生的一个想法，我也联系了大家，但目前我有一位联合促进者（co-facilitator）加入了进来，他非常有帮助，我们可以一起合作处理事情。我希望我们能再招募一位，这样我们三个人就可以尝试共同策划和发展这个空间。我认为其中两个重要的原则是，好的，是的，我们确实希望从彼此身上真正地成长，你知道的，所以要拥有这个空间和社区，以便我们能够，是的，更好地
support each other and grow from each other's experiences. I think that's really important. And the second thing I think is also a social space. So obviously the group ends up focusing on the Deakin because a lot of people in that space want to get on this course and progress within psychology. So not everyone there wants to do a declin, they want to do just progress within psychology, doing other things. So maybe the CAT course and things like that. The other part is, I think to make it sustainable, there needs to be a social element and a connection element. So we've been thinking about ways to keep that going. So we haven't yet met in person, we've had all three meetings have been on Zoom so far, but me and the other co-facilitators are trying to
互相支持并从彼此的经历中成长。我认为这非常重要。第二点，我认为它也应该是一个社交空间。显然，这个群组最终会专注于DeClin（临床心理学博士课程），因为那个空间里的许多人都想考取这个课程并在心理学领域取得进展。所以并不是那里的每个人都想读DeClin，他们只是想在心理学领域取得进展，做其他事情。比如也许是CAT（认知分析疗法）课程之类的。另一部分是，我认为要使其具有可持续性，就需要有社交元素和连接元素。所以我们一直在考虑如何维持下去。虽然我们还没有面对面聚过，到目前为止的三次会议都是通过Zoom进行的，但我和其他联合促进者正试图
organise a meet-up session. I think it's a little bit difficult because people are in different parts of the country, so there's a fair few of us in London. There's people in Liverpool and people in, I think, maybe Coventry as well. And so, yeah, where you are, there's people all over the country. And trying to bring those people together is a little bit difficult. There's about 15 of us right now. We're hoping to increase those numbers. Sometimes it can be useful to piggyback off another event so
组织一次线下见面会。我觉得这有点困难，因为大家身处国家的不同地方，我们在伦敦有一相当一部分人。还有人在利物浦，还有人我想可能在考文垂。所以，是的，你在哪里，全国各地都有人。要把这些人聚在一起有点困难。我们现在大约有15个人。我们希望能增加这个人数。有时候，借用其他活动的东风会很有用，比如
if you know that perhaps you're going to go to a particular conference or that something's happening then maybe you could meet like the day before that so that you're kind of in the same area of the country anyway but there's always there's always room for planning something but yeah it puts it puts costs up doesn't it and um but I think there is something around that connection in person that can be really special. And sometimes I think via remote technology, meeting, making friends and feeling safe can be trickier. So being in person can be really useful for that.
如果你知道自己可能会去参加某个特定的会议，或者有什么事情要发生，那么也许你可以在那之前的一天见面，这样你们无论如何都在国家的同一个地区。不过，总是有计划某些事情的空间，但，是的，这确实增加了成本，对吧？而且，我认为面对面的那种连接确实有一些非常特别的地方。有时我认为通过远程技术开会、交朋友和获得安全感会更棘手。因此，面对面交流对于这一点会非常有用。
Yeah, I think we've had to name that. So when we started the group, we thought about how we want this to be explicitly a safe space and non-judgmental space for people to come and be themselves or authentic selves and I think that's that's really important um so you're talking about events before I'm sorry I didn't really answer that how about events um there's another group which I guess kind of inspired me to create this this offshoot if you will and the snap band they're a group on LinkedIn, which I'm part of. They hold a lot of events for, I guess, people of the global majority, really.
对，我想我们必须给它定个名。所以在我们刚建立这个小组时，我们就想过要明确把它打造成一个安全、不带批判的空间，让大家能够来这里做真实的自己或本真的自我。我觉得这真的非常重要。嗯，所以你之前提到活动，不好意思，我刚刚没怎么回答好。关于活动呢，有另一个小组，我想它某种程度上启发了我来创建这个分支（如果你这么叫的话），那就是Snap Band。他们在领英上是一个群体，我是其中的一员。我想他们真的为全球多数群体的人举办了许多活动。
So they have events for that cohort, that group. And so we've been signposting people from our group to those groups, to those events, sorry. And I think that's really, really useful for people, you know, because they've got a good thing going there. So we don't want to recreate the wheel too much. We're just sending people that way. And we're thinking of what we can create in the future. What was it you said? The Snap Band?
所以他们会为那个群体、那个圈子举办活动。因此，我们会把我们小组的人引流到那些群体、那些活动去，抱歉。我觉得这对于大家来说真的非常、非常有用，你知道的，因为他们在那里做得很好。所以我们不想重复造轮子。我们只是把人往那边送。我们在考虑未来可以创建什么。你刚才说什么？Snap Band吗？
Snap Band is the name of the group. Snap Band. Could you spell it and guide us through what I'm guessing, I'm guessing that means black and Asian minorities, does it? But Snap Bam. So I think, I think it stands for supporting network for aspiring psychologists, black, Asian, minority, ethnic, I think. Something to that effect. Okay, so all of the letters are important.
Snap Band就是这个小组的名字。Snap Band。你能拼写一下并带我们了解一下它的意思吗？我猜，我猜这代表黑人和亚裔少数族裔，是吗？但是叫Snap Bam。所以我想，我想它代表的是“有抱负的心理学家的支持网络，黑人、亚裔、少数族裔”，我想是这样的。差不多就是这个意思。好的，所以所有的字母都很重要。
They're SnapBam, right. SnapBam, yes. Okay, so if people want to learn more about SnapBam, that's, did you say Twitter and Facebook? Is that where they? Yeah, they've got a group on Twitter. They've got a group on LinkedIn as well. I think there's almost like 800, 900 people in that space. So that's
它们是SnapBam，对吧。SnapBam，是的。好的，如果人们想更多地了解SnapBam，那是，你刚刚说推特和脸书吗？那是他们……？对，他们在推特上有个群。他们在领英上也有个群。我想那个空间里大概有800、900人。所以那
definitely a really, really useful space for resources. And I've gone to events in the past, and they're really good. They do really well and curate them to the people who attend. So I think it's a really good thing to do. And in our group, we'd hope to have events like that as well. But so far, we're focusing on just trying to build some connections and we hold a couple of reflective and spaces so that's what we've done in the group so far so a couple of times we someone will bring something and we'll talk about it for 10 minutes and then we'll all try and reflect on that bring our experiences and as well as having some sessions to try and develop some skills. So more recently, we introduced something where we'll provide a topic
绝对是一个获取资源非常、非常实用的空间。我过去参加过他们的活动，真的非常好。他们做得很好，并且会根据出席的人进行策划。所以我觉得这是一件非常好的事情。而在我们的小组里，我们也希望能举办这样的活动。但到目前为止，我们专注于尝试建立一些联系，我们举行了几次反思和空间活动，所以这就是我们到目前为止在小组里做的事情。因此，会有那么几次，有人带一个话题来，我们讨论10分钟，然后大家都会试着对此进行反思，带来我们的经验，同时也会有一些旨在培养某些技能的环节。最近，我们引入了一个新环节，就是我们提供一个主题
to someone, a random topic, and they'll have to speak on it for two minutes, which is a lot harder than it sounds. So someone gives you a random topic and you just have to start speaking. And it's really difficult, but our hope is that it builds a bit of confidence with people that they're able to take something random hold it digest it sit the discomfort and then bring something out that maybe is coherent maybe it's not you know but it's something about developing skills and sometimes it's quite funny I love that and it's so interesting and it's so relevant to
给某个人，一个随机的主题，他们必须就此演讲两分钟，这比听起来要难得多。所以别人给你一个随机主题，你必须立刻开始发言。这真的很难，但我们的希望是，这能在一定程度上建立人们的自信，让他们能够拿起一个随机的东西，握住它、消化它、安坐于这种不适感之中，然后表达出一些可能连贯、也可能不连贯的内容，你知道的，但这关乎技能的培养，有时还挺有趣的。我喜欢这样，而且这太有趣了，它与
ClinPsych so I spoke in a couple of episodes ago about a drop-in clinic that I used to run when I was on placement five of the course and that literally people would just turn up and I would know their name and that was it and then it's like go fix their problems in 20 minutes you know get them get them on a right path and I guess it's probably quite similar to what the work you do as well but um it was incredible and it was really a great way of learning you know and thinking on the spot and trying to be you know like you said trying to be coherent and trying to make sense but they're really really useful skills um to have and so yeah that sounds like an absolutely brilliant activity yeah yeah I think it's it's been good so far I think another thing that we we spoke about is trying to run some kind of clinics
临床心理学息息相关。我在前几集的播客里谈到过一个我以前在课程第五阶段实习时运营的代办门诊，那里的人 literalmente 就是直接出现，而我只知道他们的名字，仅此而已，然后就好像是要在20分钟内解决他们的问题，你知道的，让他们走上正确的道路。我猜这可能和你做的工作很相似，但是，这太不可思议了，这真的是一种很好的学习方式，你知道的，能够即兴思考，试着像你说的，试着保持连贯，试着说得通，但这些确实是拥有了会非常、非常实用的技能。所以，是的，听起来这绝对是一个极棒的活动。对，对，我觉得到目前为止效果很好。我想我们谈论的另一件事是尝试运营某种门诊
like you say to support people who are trying to progress in their career so there's some people who are currently working as um healthcare support workers I've also done that role and they're hoping to get into a more psychologically minded role. And so we're thinking of holding clinics and spaces where we can support people as a group. Someone can come in, speak to you, provide support. I've done that with one of the people in our group so far. He's recently just got an AP job, which is great. I can't say I can't take credit for that because I
就像你说的，去支持那些正试图在职业生涯中取得进展的人。有些人目前担任医疗保健支持工作者，我也做过这个角色，他们希望能进入一个更具心理学思维的角色。因此，我们考虑设立门诊和空间，以便我们能够以小组形式支持人们。有人可以进来，跟你谈谈，提供支持。到目前为止，我和我们组的一个人这样做过。他最近刚刚得到了一份助理心理学家（AP）的工作，这太棒了。我不能说，我不能把这归功于我，因为我
only spoke to him for 10 minutes 20 minutes but it's just really great to see that people progressing and doing well which is great love that so important and I held a very impromptu clinic in the back of an uber recently as I was on the way back from my Galway trip. So the lovely chap who was driving me, we were just chatting, and he said that originally he'd gone to uni and he'd done law. But for a variety of reasons that I unpicked during that journey, he hadn't progressed. And by the time we finished, while the homie dropped me at my house he had a plan to at least google in the gap that he had a master's to consider getting himself
只跟他谈了10分钟、20分钟，但看到人们不断取得进展并且过得很好，这真的感觉太棒了，我太喜欢了，这太重要了。我最近在我那次高尔韦（Galway）之旅回程的优步车后座上，举办了一场非常即兴的门诊。送我那位可爱的小哥，我们当时正在聊天，他说他原本上了大学学的是法律。但在我在那段旅程中挖掘出的各种原因下，他并没有取得进展。等到我们结束时，就在这位好兄弟把我送到我家的时候，他已经有了一个计划，至少去谷歌搜索一下他拥有的硕士学位的空白处，考虑让自己
back on the law path and I love that and like he was so fired up by the time we finished that sort of 20 minute journey the it's these micro interventions that can potentially have the difference to make a real difference and to inspire hope and possibility I think yeah no that's a really nice story it kind of makes me think of some of the stuff that we do sometimes in A&E and like single session work so you're not sure someone's turned up in A&E yes they keep attending but because we're a nine to five service, we don't always see people out of hours. And so if they are down there in Amy,
重新回到法律的道路上。我太喜欢这个了，而且就像他结束那段大约20分钟的旅程时那样斗志昂扬，正是这些微干预，有可能带来真正的改变，并激发出希望和无限可能，我觉得。是的，这真是一个非常温馨的故事。这让我想起我们在急诊科（A&E）有时会做的一些事情，比如单次治疗。所以你不确定某人是否出现在急诊科，是的，他们不断前来，但因为我们是一个朝九晚五的服务机构，我们并不总能在工作时间之外见到人。所以如果他们在急诊科，
rush down and try and do a single session with them in the hope that that will start a process, you know, that we can get back involved with. So, yeah, that's kind of what I think you've got when you're saying that. It's all about potentially being the difference that makes the difference isn't it and meeting them where they're at when they've got the capacity to hear that and to work with those changes so I will likely never know the end of that story and that's a similar thing with with single session work isn't it that you don't get to know but very occasionally people will contact
我们会赶过去，尝试和他们进行一次单次治疗，希望能以此开启一个我们能够重新介入的过程。所以，是的，当你这么说时，我大致就是这么想的。这一切都关乎于成为带来改变的那个不同之处，不是吗？在他们有能力倾听并配合这些改变时，在他们所在的地方与他们相遇。所以我可能永远不会知道那个故事的结局，单次治疗也是如此，不是吗？你无从得知结局，但极少数情况下，人们会联系
you and go you know you probably don't remember me. But and, you know, you hear, oh, it made this massive change to me, you know, spending that time together. And so, oh, I just absolutely love it. So keep doing what you're doing personally and professionally. If you had any top tip for reducing burnout in aspiring psychologists, what might that be, Jonathan? That's a really, really good question. I think burnout is probably quite common within aspiring psychologists. I know that me, myself, I've definitely, definitely been through that. I think it's trying to quickly race through all these hoops and gaps that we feel are in front of us. So for example, when I work as a healthcare assistant on a ward, I also volunteered as an AP in a different city. And so I was doing the four days a week on this ward, driving to the city two days a week and then coming back and then going back to work.
你，对你说：“你知道的，你可能不记得我了，但是……”你知道的，你听到：“哦，这给我带来了巨大的改变，你知道的，我们一起度过的这段时间。”所以，哦，我真的太喜欢了。所以，请继续在个人和职业上做你正在做的事。乔纳森，如果你有什么关于减少有抱负的心理学家职业倦怠的绝招，那会是什么呢？这是一个真的非常、非常好的问题。我觉得职业倦怠在有抱负的心理学家中间可能相当普遍。我知道我自己，我绝对、绝对经历过这个阶段。我想这是因为我们试图快速冲过所有我们觉得横亘在眼前的障碍和差距。例如，当我在病房担任医疗保健助理时，我还兼任了另一个城市的助理心理学家志愿者。所以我一周有四天在这个病房工作，一周有两天开车去那个市，然后回来，接着又回去上班。
And very, very very quickly within a couple of months was starting to burn out and I think at that time what I used was the community around me the people around me and to kind of focus on the things that brought me joy you know and so that included playing sports playing football and going out with my friends seeing my family that kind of thing, prioritising those things, even though yes I wanted to move forward in my career, I think prioritising those things is really useful. And again that's part of the reason why I think this BMAP space is really important because some aspiring psychologists can feel like they need to go to um i guess different places in the
非常、非常、非常快地，在几个月内我就开始感到职业倦怠了。我想当时我依靠的是我周围的社群、我周围的人，以及专注于那些能给我带来快乐的事情，你知道的，所以这包括打运动、踢足球、和朋友外出、见家人之类的。优先考虑这些事情，尽管是的，我想要在职业生涯中前进，但我认为优先考虑这些事情是非常有用的。这也是为什么我认为这个BMAP空间非常重要的部分原因，因为一些有抱负的心理学家可能会觉得自己需要去到
in the country so maybe like from oscantorpe or into scotland let's say they're from london going all over the country and to do these ap jobs and their community can't always follow them so what i'm hoping is that this space can be a constant for people you know and they might know people in that city and people can feel more comfortable and wherever they are yeah I think being part of the community really in summary to answer your question could be really really useful oh what a lovely warming and totally on brand um answer that was um so thank you so much for your time in talking with us today and guiding us through a little bit about your story a little bit about what got you into psychology you know what you're
全国不同的地方，比如说从斯肯索普（Scunthorpe）到苏格兰，比方说他们来自伦敦，跑遍全国去从事这些助理心理学家的工作，而他们的社群并不总能跟随他们。所以我希望的是，这个空间能成为人们生活中的一个常态，你知道的，他们可能会在那个城市认识人，无论他们在哪里，人们都能感到更舒适。是的，作为社群的一部分，总结来回答你的问题，真的会非常、非常有用。哦，这是一个多么温馨、完全符合品牌调性的回答啊。所以非常感谢你今天花时间与我们交谈，并向我们介绍了一点你的故事，一门心思带你进入心理学的东西，你知道的，你
doing currently and also how you're trying to support encourage and change people's experience of feeling othered or feeling lonely or feeling isolated and wondering if this is even the right career for them. So you're doing such incredible work, Jonathan. Could you just remind us where the best place to contact you on socials is? And I'll make sure I put that in the show notes and we'll have it on screen as well. Thank you. So we're on LinkedIn. So BMAP are on LinkedIn. And I personally am on LinkedIn as Jonathan Paddy.
目前在做什么，以及你如何努力支持、鼓励和改变人们的经历，让他们不再感到被边缘化、孤独或孤立，并想知道这是否真的是适合他们的职业。所以你正在做如此不可思议的工作，乔纳森。你能提醒一下大家在社交媒体上联系你的最佳途径是什么吗？我一定会把它写进节目简介里，屏幕上也会显示出来。谢谢。我们在领英上。所以BMAP在领英上。我个人也在领英上，叫乔纳森·帕迪（Jonathan Paddy）。
And we've got an email address which is bmap2023 at gmail.com and I think those places would be great to contact us we haven't yet got Twitter so we'll be working on that but yeah I just want to say it's not just me yes I thought of the idea but when I spoke to the people they'd also had the idea as well and I guess it was just about reaching out to people and now I've got people on board who are really helping to to support and bring this to life which is great good well I'm delighted to be able to get word out hopefully further and um is it is it okay for international applicants to contact you as well because we do have listeners internationally okay that's really
我们有一个电子邮箱，是 bmap2023@gmail.com，我觉得通过这些地方联系我们会很棒。我们还没有推特，所以我们会为此努力的。但是，是的，我只想说这不只是我一个人。是的，我想到了这个主意，但当我跟其他人谈起时，他们其实也想到了这个主意。我想这只是关于向人们伸出援手，现在我身边有了真正提供支持并把这一切变为现实的伙伴们，这太棒了。很好，我很高兴能够让这个消息传播得更远，而且，国际申请者联系你也可以吗？因为我们确实有国际听众。好的，这真的
I didn't talk about that at all did I really so our group is for aspiring psychologists and we have we basically take anybody who has already done a psychology degree so if you've done a psychology degree or conversion degree that's fine if you identify as a as a man and you're as a black man then yes get involved I think and we also accepting of trainees so that's one thing we spoke about at the last meeting i think having aspiring psychologists and trainees in the same space feels like it could work and we're not quite sure how we could manage um qualified um members of staff just because of the power so we're trying to figure that out
我根本没谈过这个，对吧？所以我们的小组是为有抱负的心理学家准备的，我们基本上接纳任何已经完成心理学学位的人。所以如果你完成了心理学学位或转换学位，那没问题。如果你认同自己是一名男性，并且是一名黑人男性，那么是的，参与进来吧。我想我们同时也接纳实习生，这是我们在上次会议上谈过的一点，我觉得让有抱负的心理学家和实习生处在同一个空间里是行得通的。我们不太确定该如何管理拥有正式资质的员工，仅仅是因为权力的原因，所以我们正在努力弄清楚这一点。
um in terms of international if people are hoping to um get on any of the courses in the UK I think yeah yeah we're more than more than happy more than open because that's kind of where our expertise is we do I don't know anything about psychology in other countries no okay brilliant well it might be that as your own group members evolve and grow that you develop just naturally a qualified you know they almost you almost graduate to the qualified group um so i think that i think it will do it itself naturally with time but well done for giving yourself permission to do that um and you know making the difference that you want to see in psychology it's incredibly admirable and i hope that you want to see in psychology it's incredibly admirable and I hope that you yeah I hope that you help many many people and I hope that you get on training very soon too um sounds like you're doing
就国际而言，如果人们希望进入英国的任何课程，我觉得，是的，是的，我们非常、非常乐意，也非常、非常开放，因为这正是我们的专业领域所在。我们不，我对其他国家的心理学一无所知。不，好吧，太棒了，随着你们小组自身的演变和成长，你们可能会自然而然地发展出一个有资质的群体，你知道的，他们几乎，你们几乎会“毕业”进入有资质的群体。所以我觉得随着时间推移，它会自然而然地实现。但祝贺你给予自己这样做的许可，并且（你知道的）在你希望看到改变的领域做出你想要的改变，这真是令人钦佩。我希望你，我希望你帮助许许多多的人，我也希望你很快就能顺利开始培训。听起来你正在做
great stuff yeah thank you yeah no I hope so too I hope we can get people through the the process really it's it can be really tough so um yeah having this this here for people and I think it'll help support me but should also help support other people. Yeah. Brilliant. Thank you so much for your time. Thank you so much for having me. Really happy to be here. You're so welcome. Oh, what a wonderful chat that was. I feel really excited for the profession of clinical psychology and how people are just able to stand up and be the difference to make the difference. I think it's really encouraging. If you're doing something
很棒的事情。是的，谢谢。是的，不，我也希望如此。我希望我们能帮助人们真正走过这个流程，这真的很艰难。所以，是的，为人们提供这个支持，我认为这不仅能帮到我，也应该能帮到其他人。是的，太棒了。非常感谢你抽出时间。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。不用客气。哦，这是一场多么精彩的对话。我对临床心理学这个职业感到非常兴奋，看到人们能够挺身而出，成为带来改变的那股力量。我觉得这真的非常鼓舞人心。如果你在心理学领域正在做一些
exciting in the field of psychology or you'd like to pitch a different podcast episode to me, please do get in contact with me on my socials like i said i'm dr marianne trent everywhere and if you want to replay any of the compassionate q a sessions go to dr marianne trent on youtube click the live tab because that's where they hang out there and you should be able to see them all and there's of course details in the show notes but yeah I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast which will be available for you from Monday at 6am. Take care of yourselves and thank you so much for being part of my world. if you're looking to become a psychologist
激动人心的事情，或者你想向我推介一档不同的播客节目，请务必通过我的社交媒体与我联系。就像我说的，我到处都是 Dr Marianne Trent。如果你想重温任何有同理心的问答环节，请去 YouTube 搜索 Dr Marianne Trent，点击“直播”（Live）标签页，因为那是它们存放的地方，你应该能找到所有这些内容。当然，节目简介里也有详细信息。但是，是的，我期待着在我们的下一期播客节目中与你相聚，该节目将于周一早上6点为你准时上线。照顾好自己，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想成为一名心理学家，
then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to
那么就让这个播客成为你的指南，有它在身旁陪伴，助你迈向获得资质的征程，这就是《有抱负的心理学家》（The Aspiring Psychologist）。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。这让我惊叹于通往这一目标的道路竟然有如此之多，而且并没有哪一条是完美的途径去
become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为其中一员，这让我充满了信心，让我觉得自己并没有做错，也减轻了内心的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对会推荐这本书，它能让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就不会把书放下了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。